yes Salem we're back the Sanderson
sisters are back and they're running in
Hocus Pocus 2. in this resurrection of
the story The only thing more
petrifyingly plentiful than Winnie Mary
and Sarah's Antics are the hidden
references to the first film stick
around and we'll lift the spell to
reveal these hidden gems there are so
many reasons to see Hocus Pocus too
number one it looks fabulous doesn't it
Billy butcherson's hair and the rest of
his look don't seem to have aged a day
even though 29 years have passed since
the first movie Hocus Pocus 2 actor Doug
Jones said to have all four of us back
and looking almost exactly the same as
we did almost 30 years ago it looked
like seconds had passed in 29 years
because I was wearing a prosthetic I'm
exactly the same weight exactly the same
build as I was 29 years ago so it looked
freakishly the same it was the same week
from the first movie turns out the wig
had been sitting on some display but
once it was needed it was brought to set
to head back where it belonged thank you
number two maybe it's a reference to the
previous film or maybe it's just a merry
thing either way weird tickled to see
Mary Sanderson barking up another Tree
in Hocus Pocus too
good girl Mary now sit Shake A Paw and
leave those children alone
number three that signature Sanderson
slant has been a defining part of Mary's
character since the first moment we saw
her in the first film and with such
attention to detail in Hocus Pocus too
how could they miss one this distinct
why is Mary's mouth stuck on the
opposite side in the original film
Mary's mouth slant is to the right in
Hocus Pocus 2 we notice it has shifted
to the left Kathy and Jimmy had her
reasons explaining it's on the other
side mainly because it's so hard for me
to do it on the side I did it on 30
years ago we can justify it because
there's a scene at the beginning where
Winnie slaps me and my mouth goes to the
other side and sticks it's just a
surprise you do a film you don't know
how people are going to react to it
number four in their effort to brew the
life potion the girls find themselves
needing to retrace their steps from
their previous night on Earth this is in
order to determine what they need to do
next while they're remembering their
distant past Mary recalls we were in the
cottage the boys were in the cages and
that's when that Sunrise drunk tested
describing a moment from the first film
Mary is referencing bullies ice and Jay
who we last Saw imprisoned in cages
above the sisters cauldrons in the first
movie we're really sorry we think you're
really cute
number five you never know what you'll
see during the Sanderson sisters search
for the mayor Winifred peeks through the
window to find a couple watching a movie
while the antics of the Sanderson
sisters often get the most screen time
if we pay careful attention in this
moment we notice that the movie This
unsuspecting couple is watching well
it's the original Hocus Pocus from 1993.
get out of my house
make us
number six clever nods and callbacks to
the first film seem to be hiding
everywhere in Hocus Pocus 2. take
Cassie's house for example when we
compare it to Alison's mansion from the
original film we can't help but draw a
comparison number seven Cassie's uncanny
house resemblance isn't the only thing
we noticed on this doorstep in Hocus
Pocus 2 Cassie opens the door to greet
Becca and Izzy and steps out wearing a
tie-dye shirt that bears a remarkable
resemblance to the shirt Max wore at the
beginning of the first film is this a
nod to the original or just another
Timeless tie-dye moment we have been
waiting to hear that since we booked the
movie I think number eight can a piece
of clothing have a ghost we might never
know but we do know that Cassie's tan
colored sweater and Hocus Pocus too sure
does look a lot like Allison's sweater
from the 1993 film what are they trying
to tell us here I know you guys are mad
about that how could you not know
because you you didn't tell me number
nine are we surprised in the first film
Sarah and her sisters find themselves
hiding from the townsfolk after they
finished draining Emily Binks of her
soul
Winifred calls out through the door in
an attempt to deceive the townsfolk it
might have worked if Sarah hadn't added
loudly
well she does it again in Hocus Pocus 2.
as Reverend trasky and an angry mob of
Salem citizens approached the Sanderson
sisters door in the opening sequence
young Sarah exclaims we're not here once
again spoiling the Sanderson secret oh
Sarah it's just remarkable number 10 any
Hocus Pocus story would feel incomplete
without a signature musical number
particularly a haunting cover of the
witchy classic one way or another but to
add to the charm and Enchantment of this
sequence Hocus Pocus 2 has buried even
more Treasures for us to unearth in the
form of references to the first film you
might notice many of the dancers in this
scene are wearing costumes from the
first movie including a billy butcherson
costume Mrs Dennison's Madonna outfit
and even the three Sanderson sisters all
Chante number 11 they just had to ask
while this moment might not have been
scripted in the original it was certain
certainly a part of the viewing
experience for many at the time in the
first Hocus Pocus kids would ask and
parents would tense up Hocus Pocus 2
calls back to the experience of that
scene with a nod to the first movie and
even an answer from an on-screen
character Gilbert what's a Virgin uh
that is a uh a person who has never
lit a candle number 12. not all
references to the first film are so
obvious walking through the Festival
after school Hocus Pocus two characters
Becca and Izzy spot a billboard
featuring Cassie's father clearly a
descendant of the Reverend from the
1600s Salem on the billboard just over
the shoulder of Cassie's family portrait
you can see a photo of the original
Denison house from the first film number
13. we found the tale of the Sanderson
sisters simply enchanting maybe that's
why it has stood the test of time even
though they weren't able to fulfill
their youthful quest in the first film a
few things from the first movie however
didn't make it through the 29-year
Journey Mary's flying vacuum for one one
of the things that I love about it is
that it's it's so wholesome no it seems
the old Hoover must have given up the
ghost somewhere along the way and while
when he seems to be able to summon a
classically witchy broom anywhere she
goes Sanderson sisters Sarah and Mary
were left to improvise once again it's
taken away a little bit of the length of
the runs we do and the kind of time we
spend up high in the air Sarah trades
her beloved mop from the first film for
a slick Swiffer Wet jet in Hocus Pocus
2. and Mary's Hefty Hoover gets replaced
by a pair of robotic vacuums that later
come to their rescue when the sisters
are trapped in a ring of salt magical
that's our favorite part right yes I
love it number 14 no we're not talking
about collagen or elastin this isn't the
first time we've seen Winnie use Sarah
as the guinea pig the Sanderson sisters
of Hocus Pocus 2 find themselves trapped
in a circle of result by an escaping
Becca to test the powers of the magical
cage Winifred pushes Sarah into the
force field smashing Sarah's face
against the invisible barrier we are
reminded of the time Winnie used Sarah
to test the safety of the Black River in
the first film leading Sarah to exclaim
one of her most famous lines
there is a magical Garden's worth of
charming references to the original film
so many that we're sure we've missed
some so what do you think share with us
some of your favorite secret treats from
Hocus Pocus 2.